so many of us make new year's
resolutions to try and improve our
health and wellness hello my name is
Gayle do that every year but our medical
contributor that's dr. Tara Narula says
the keys to a healthy 2020 go way beyond
exercising more and eating right which
is everybody says they're going to do
that good to see you dr. Tara you're -
Happy New Year Happy New Year we got the
festive memo I like it so what do you
think we all should do to start up a new
healthy New Year
well Jill talked about taking charge of
your finances and people need to take
charge of their health in just the same
way and a really good way to do that is
to schedule an appointment an annual
visit with your primary care provider
this we should all go every year right
well there's something there actually is
some debate about that but definitely
worth a check in certainly if you
haven't been in a while and this is an
important time to talk about prevention
screening lifestyle and behavioral
changes and really just develop that
relationship with your primary care
provider and so during this visit you
want to come armed with some questions
you want to ask about vaccines am i due
for any booster shots or annual vaccines
like the flu shot you want to ask about
preventive screening like colonoscopies
mammograms pap smears you also want to
update your physician that any changes
in your health and he new symptoms
you've noticed and then one really
important thing that we don't often do
is look through our medication list and
look through our meds and say do I
really need to still be on this
medication am I on the correct dosage
doesn't interact with my other meds so I
tell my patients take us a picture of
all your bottles and bring that photo in
on your phone and show me and last but
not least is really being honest and not
embarrassed about talking about things
that you may not think are relevant
things like what's going on in your
financial life have you lost some income
am i playing to your ability to pay for
your medications in your social life are
you having some sort of difficult times
with your spouse or your children that's
increasing stress so things that you
really excitement exact because the
doctor can help help you he or she if
they don't have all the information
that's right you also say family history
is very important yes we really don't
emphasize this enough but you don't just
share your genes with your family you
share your behaviors the way that you
eat whether you're more sedentary or
active and environmental exposures and
all of this can play into your future
health risks so it's important to ask
your family at your next family
gathering or on the phone do we have any
chronic diseases that run in our family
like diabetes or heart disease or cancer
any substance abuse issues any mental
health issues
you know we're doing a whole big thing
about mental health we're calling it
taking the shame and blame out of
discussing mental health how do we take
stock of our mental health this year
2020 so one everybody's starting to talk
about it finally it's coming out of the
closets of this bowl which I'm so glad
to one out of five Americans have a
mental health illness that they're down
by five yes and so it's really important
because it doesn't just play into our
well-being it does affect our physical
health as well so it's a good time to
take stock of how you're handling stress
anger anxiety depression and really talk
to your doctor about that and many times
I spend much of my visit even telling my
patients to schedule a visit with a
psychologist or a psychiatrist someone
who can really help them even just by
talking through some of their issues and
giving them extra support you recommend
going even if people hadn't thought
about going I do I do if they're dealing
with a lot it can be so helpful and as
we on this first day of 20/20 what's the
one health resolution you wish everybody
would make mindfulness practicing
mindfulness this is my health resolution
this year which is really this idea
about being in the present moment
focused on what's happening in the
present aware of that not on the future
or the past and we know that mindfulness
practices things like meditation you can
improve both mental and physical health
do you meditate on a regular basis you
don't but I'm about to for some apps
that are gonna help me do this I
recommend headspace I've tried but it's
so hard about yeah it's very good it's
so hard to clear my mind but mindfulness
I think that's a good resolution yes I
think I'm going to take that to you
Thank You Cara Narula Happy New Year
Happy New Year
you